my name is Diane Kraus I'm a professor
at Yale University where I'm also
associate director of the Yale stem cell
center the project that we're very
excited to publish is about these
incredibly fascinating cells called
megakaryocytes so megakaryocytes are the
cells in the bone marrow that are
responsible for making platelets and
platelets are necessary for blood
clotting and one of the things that's
been a mystery about megakaryocytes is
how they get so large they're called
megakaryocytes because they're huge we
know that this is from a process called
endo mitosis where the DNA divides but
the cell doesn't so it doesn't undergo
cytokinesis after the cell divides and
this work elucidate some of the
mechanisms that take place to prevent
cytokinesis from occurring even though
DNA division has occurred this project
actually investigates what genes are
involved in making sure that the cell
undergoes endo mitosis rather than
regular mitosis which leads to SATA
cases and actually the separation of the
cell megakaryocytes undergo two
different kinds of cell division in
order to finish their endo mitotic
cycles so megakaryocytes as I said can
be very very large and they can go up to
128 n so they have many many copies of
the nucleus and what had been shown
prior to our work is that this seems to
occur in two different phases the first
phase is when the cell is going from 2 n
2 for n so most cells are 2n and then
when they're undergoing cell division
mitosis you have two copies of the
nuclei and then when the cell finishes
cytokinesis you have two separate cells
in the megakaryocytes from the 2n to
foreign the very first endo mitotic
cycle they get almost to the end of
cytokinesis but they don't complete it
for the subsequent endo mitotic cycles
for n2 a 10 a 10 to 16 etc the cells
don't even start cytokinesis you just
see a little bit of a blip in the
outside of the membrane and what we're
showing in this paper is that there
really are two different stages with two
different mechanisms one of the things
you need to know to understand the work
that we're publishing here is that
proteins called wanting exchange factors
activate row a which activates actin
polymerization
sation in the cytogenetic furrow the
first thing that happens is the cleavage
furrow starts to form and that requires
actin polymerization and there's a
single guanine exchange factor that's
necessary for that and that's called ECT
too much later during the cleavage
furrow contraction there's a different
guanine exchange factor that's necessary
for the very end when the cells are
about to separate and that one's called
gif h1 and what we ended up showing in
this paper is that death h1 is
downregulated at the two end of for
end-stage of endo mitosis and then its
subsequent rounds of endo mitosis when
you barely even see a cleavage furrow
form the ECT two is missing so this is a
novel finding that showing that
different guanine exchange factors are
differentially regulated at stages of
endo mitosis and the megakaryocytes UN
gal the first author on the paper came
to the lab with a lot of expertise and
guanine exchange factors and then her
postdoctoral studies in the lab made the
link between guanine exchange factors
and endo mitosis she has since moved on
in her career and is now an investigator
at boston biomedical another aspect of
our studies shows that MK l1 a
transcriptional cofactor regulates GAF
h1 for the first stage of endo mitosis
in this time-lapse study you can see the
second stage of endo mitosis occurring
the DNA separates and is pulled to
opposite ends of the cell but rather
than dividing into two separate cells
the cell has a boarded cell division and
remains one cell with multiple nuclei so
the work that we're doing is relevant
not only to normal hematopoiesis and how
normal megakaryocytes mature to make
platelets but it's also relevant to
leukemia because in leukemia for example
in mega carry elastic leukemia the
problem is that the cells don't fully
mature instead they stay as 2n blasts
and we think we found a link between
normal mega carry side of pieces and
what goes wrong in megakaryocytic
leukemia and it might have to do with
that gaff h1 that gap h one that is
missing in normal megakaryocytes when
they abort the cytokinesis to become 4n
cells the next step what we're doing now
in the
is directly testing the hypothesis that
mutations in MK l1 will cause elevated
levels of get h1 and that those elevated
levels of death h1 will not allow the
cells to undergo endo mitosis and then
the question is if a cell is inhibited
from undergoing endo mitosis will it
actually be inhibited in its maturation
we predict that the maturation will be
inhibited but we don't know yet and
that's where we're what we're doing
right now